the anna delvey so you went to visit her
in custody she was like
so how's the shoot going and i was just
like oh i said it's going well
to building something special 40 million
alone maybe it's what's helped if you
stop thinking about me like everyone
else like basic you know
julia i binge these screeners so fast
you're so great the show's so good so
just first of all my compliments and
thank you for making this show thank you
so much
my first question how does it feel to be
a card-carrying member of shondaland
it you know it's it's such a i it's such
a privilege i i i really you know
shonda's such a brilliant writer and
you know it was such a joy just saying
her lines
so i i feel really grateful
and saying them in that accent you know
i gotta ask about the accent i just had
some questions
i have a question
what's you wearing you look poor
i spent a lot of the episodes
i'm like it's a little german a little
new york sometimes what is the accent
in terms of what it's made up of and how
you created it
well
it's definitely i'm like it's definitely
not new york but
it's americanized she was born in russia
she grew up most of her most of her life
in germany and
you know but she but she was convincing
people that she was german that she
wasn't russian so she's not gonna have a
russian accent and um the first thing i
had to learn was a
german accent and then ration and then
you know uh
put it all together put it all together
and then she learns english
like a brit because
you know she's
you're in europe they don't learn
english like an american they yeah learn
british english so
that that that was kind of in there too
very subtly and then you know she came
to america and she spent a lot of time
with americans and being in fork and
musically
it shouldn't sound european musically it
sounded uh american
you know was it hard to stop speaking in
the accent
it was no you know it
i i got to a place where i i always want
to get to a place where i'm so
comfortable in the accent that i will
speak all hours of the day
with even when i'm off work or if i'm at
a restaurant and i'm ordering i i'll
speak in the accent until i'm
comfortable give me back that money
please why you being like this is so
dramatic but
you know one of the reasons why i love
doing accents is it's almost it feels
like it's almost like wearing a wig
there's
like separation between
uh the character and the actor um
especially
it's it's hard when you have an intense
day and then you get home and
you're carrying all that emotion from
that other character but then you're
also carrying your emotion so you're
really carrying like two people's
emotions and this this one had a lot of
emotion um i'm seeing you with your
amazing blonde hair now were there wigs
for anna
yes yes we had every look was a wig
there was in my hair in in the in
inventing anna so you did in some ways
get to take anna off at the end of the
day yeah i took anna off at the end of
the day i also had you know fake teeth
um
yeah we you know there was a moment
right before filming and we were doing
testing looks and um
there was one picture where she was
smiling which i it's very rare that i
see kind of her smiling in a way um
and then i noticed that she had like i
have a gap tooth she i noticed that she
had like perfectly straight teeth and i
was like oh this will not only change
the way that i speak so i will sound
more like her but also just my you know
she has more of a baby doll face you
know it's it's it'll change like
everything wow well the transformation's
amazing and of course so are the clothes
what was it like to wear those items and
did you get to keep any of them
um it was amazing you know it was a
really nice breath of fresh air after
ruth as much as i love ozark and ruth
you know the clothes on delvie are next
level as you can see
um and i did get to keep some of the
clothes uh
but i have a favorite piece you got to
wear i mean there were so many looks
like every day i was like this is my new
favorite this is my new favorite
um but a lot of the looks like the big
big looks were archived so which i
understand um like you know the iconic
that elia dress
that she wears that baby doll black
dress with the celine glasses that felt
the most anna delvey
the anna delvey so you went to visit her
in custody
do you feel like you know anna delvey i
don't think
no i mean yes and no i really know anna
in one sense but in the other sense i
can't say that i do because i don't
think i think anna is still knowing
herself
very well put um what did you two
discuss i i heard that she wanted to
hear the accent
yeah she she was like so how's the shoot
going and i was just like oh i said it's
going well
and she's like
so how are you applying me what's he
doing and it was like um and i started
freaking out inside internally it's like
super intimidating you know
i didn't want her to get disappointed um
and uh because obviously i still care
i'm playing her you know and
and um
i i didn't know what to do so i started
mirroring her and i was like how are you
playing
and she and she was like she's like oh
my god that's so funny and then i
started mirroring her oh my god that's
so funny and it was just it was really
funny and then jessica um pressler was
there the person who wrote the cut
article and it just got super meta and
it was like such an out-of-body
experience what world am i in wow wow
yeah it's almost like i wish that there
was a camera there because it was like
that almost was like a movie itself in a
way wow
um now i do have to ask you i don't know
if you saw or read the whole thing but
anna wrote a piece that came out today
in business insider and she said she
won't be watching the show and that she
felt like a bit of an afterthought
and i wondered what your reaction to
that was and what you think she would
think of the show
i mean i never here's the thing anna
i respect whatever anna does you know in
terms of whether she wants to watch the
show or if she doesn't want to watch the
show that's her choice and that's
totally fine she doesn't have to watch
the show
every day men do far worse things than
anything i've allegedly done
anna stole a jet what's going on who are
you
i never made the show in anticipation
thinking that she's gonna watch it um or
if she did watch it great if not that's
fine too
um
but yeah i mean
yeah she's yeah she i respect whatever
she wants to do
don't get yourself killed
like you [ __ ] care
also wanted to ask you final season of
ozark is coming what can you tease for
part two how did you react when you saw
how it all ended
you know it's always funny because i i
i don't i forget when i'm shoot like
what i'm shooting by the time it comes
out um and i forgot like how intense it
was
you know but yeah it's so
you're just gonna have to wait i mean it
gets more intense it gets very intense